okay this is the functional programming
tool kits my name is Scott the lotion
that's me on Twitter and I have a
website f-sharp for fun and profit calm
which is about F sharp as you can
probably guess I'm going to be using f
sharp for the code examples
in fact these are this is a concept
talks a big-picture kind of concept
taught so these concepts should pretty
much work in all modern programming
languages maybe not in COBOL but they
should certainly work in you know
JavaScript or Python or whatever so the
first thing is why do functional
programmers use of strange words they
use you know words like functor
metamorphism and applicative and monoid
and carrying an monad that worse word of
all and I think part of the point of
this talk is to say that really yeah
don't be like homer and and like put
your hands to is it's not that scary
it's not the really this scary it's just
that unfamiliar and so one of the goals
of this talk is to make you more
familiar with some of these worse so you
know unfortunately these words are not
friendly words if they were called AG
repeatable or chainable or mapable like
thing would be an oo or something then
they might not be so scary and you might
just say well I don't know what they
mean but I can learn what they mean it's
not a problem but because they're kind
of mathematical sounding words people
get very scared and very cut off so
please don't do that it actually is
worth learning them and I'll tell you
what's really scary is obviously on your
programming if you're not a novice of it
on your programming you've got all these
words like polymorphism and inheritance
and interface and generics covariance
and solid and solid is five other things
and then this IRC and di and MVC Emma so
you forget if you're experienced
probably I hope you experience an oo you
forget that there's all these
complicated words in oo - so functional
programming isn't actually any worse
than our that way it's just they're
different words so don't ever say that
fronting the following words are scary
now even though these have a
mathematical basis they're actually very
useful tools in everyday programming
it's not just academic concepts that
we're talking about here and so this
talk is really to show you some of these
tools and how can actually be used to
solve real-world problems not just kind
of academic problems so just like our
people have our patterns and so on
functional programmers have a standard
set of tools
I call this the functional toolkit and
just imagine just like you have our tool
box and there's a bunch of things you
know you have a saw and a hammer and a
wrench and a spoon or whatever
functional programmers they have map
they have returned they have Traverse
spines lifts that map combined whatever
there's actually about 11 tools that you
need to understand so these are these
are tools designed for problem solving
like I say they're not just academic
tools with no purpose these are actually
useful tools that are used every day and
they solve the kind of problems that you
have as a developer so you know how do
you compose things how do you make
bigger things from smaller things how do
you combine things how do you aggregate
things how do you loop over collections
and stuff how do you work with effects
now I'm going to explain what I mean by
fix later one but effects is basically
some extra enhanced data or something so
when you mix things up when you mix a
list and an on list how do you work with
that when you need to chain lists or
tasks or a sinks or promises in series
how do you do that if you want to do the
thought from parallel how do you do that
if you want to mix and match lists and
then task something how do you do that
so these are very common problems and
this is what the toolkit solves so I'm
going to give these things names so the
compose function whatever isn't you know
language is composition fold is
typically is for looping over
collections you can combine things and
reduce things with functions typically
call combined and reduce math in return
a very common bind and flatmap a very
common apply lift is it other functions
sequence and reverse these are all
really common functions in your talk
yeah like I say it's about 11 of them 12
of them whatever and if you know how
these will work you have all the tools
you need to do function programming this
is actually a smaller toolset then
probably 400 now of course there's the
jargon version of these works this is
the like the friendly version the jargon
version is when you're talking about
combining things and aggregating is you
use moloids and when you're working with
effects you use things like functors
monads and effectives so this is the
jargon version and I'm going to mix and
match between the jargon version and the
non-jarring version so don't cut off
so this talk I'm not going to talk about
Manos I'm going to talk about basically
working with the fix and how you work
with them in parallel how you chain them
together how you mix and match them this
one so that's what this talk is about
right now it's only an hour and there's
a lot to cover so it's just like one of
those tour buses you go to a city and
you like see you just drive by the sites
really quickly that's what this is like
you're really not gonna kind of get
everything in so hopefully they will
demystify and you can go away and like
learn on your by yourself and get more
into it if you want so don't worry if
you don't understand everything I can
say it's really just to demystify and
make sure they stop being scary so I'm
going to talk about the core principles
of functional programming
then what about function transform which
is really the main idea behind all these
things and then I look at some of the
tools which is map bind and lift and
then I'll look at a real world example
of how you combine all these tools
together to actually do something useful
and it's really how you think about
using these tools this sort of way of
approaching problems so part 1 I'm going
to talk about functional programming
what are the principles are touching
programming now this is my take on it
everyone has slightly different takes
and I like to begin in my talk because I
have to really emphasize this every
single time so one of the main
principles is that functions are things
right and I like to use a little railway
track analogy you like if you're playing
with wooden railway States isn't it and
that means you can use them like
integers and strings and dates and stuff
they're just things you can pass them
around as parameters and then the second
really important principle is it used
composition as your fundamental tool for
building things and that is like Lego so
if you know how to use toy railways and
you know how to use Lego you know
everything about functional programming
so let's look at functions as things so
here's I like this railway track analogy
a lot you're gonna see me doing over and
over again so imagine there's a little
rail we reckon there's like a tunnel on
the railway track and something goes
into the tunnel as one thing and it
comes out as another thing so it goes in
as an apple and it comes out as a banana
so we call this as a function
turns apples into bananas okay and we
write it Apple Arrow banana now here's
the thing unlike object ID programming
functions or standalone things they're
not attached to a class and that means
you can use it just like an int or
string what it was just a value that you
could pass around and in particular
because they're standalone things that
means they're reusable so the way you
use functions is very different than the
way you use objects because any function
can typically be used anywhere in your
code so let's look at a function that
has a normal input but it spits out a
function there's an output all right so
you can have a function that spits out
functions and output you can have a
function as an input that returns a
normal thing you can even have you know
a normal function but it has a special
kind of function parameter that controls
how the function works the size which we
in our we call that strategy pattern so
you know that's all it is that's
watching the program right there but you
can really build complex systems from
this kind of basics so for example you
can have a function that returns a
function that constructs another
function that is another function
transform you know it can get really
complicated but the principles are based
basically straightforward and most of
the tools in the functional toolkit our
function transform as they are functions
you feed them in a function and they
spit out another function which is
tweaked of the original function it's
been changed somehow so I I'm calling
those function transformers so that's
functions as things and the second thing
is you used composition everywhere and
if you're familiar with the Lego you
already know how to do this so in Lego
there is actually a philosophy behind
Lego and is that all the pieces are
designed to be connected that's the
thing number one and if you connect any
two LEGO pieces you get another thing
that can is another kind of piece of
Lego you can still kind of keep going
right and the pieces are reusable right
so here's some Lego and notice that
every single piece of Lego has a little
bump on it or multiple bumps on it
and that's how you connect them together
right but they're designed that way when
you design when you make a piece of Lego
they actually think about where to put
the bumps right they don't just design
it without bond
and because of these connection things
you can take two pieces and connect them
and make another piece and then you can
take another take that and take another
piece and take that and connect another
piece and so on this thing that you can
keep getting more and more pieces you
don't need a special adapter to add a
Lego to another piece of Lego and you
can keep adding and adding
you never have to run out you know you
never have to stop at some point because
you've run out of bumps and of course
Lego is reusable you can make something
out of Lego and you can take it apart
and put it together another way so
that's why I Lego is such a fun thing to
play with and the reason why the pieces
are reusable is they literally do not
have strings attached you can take you
know if a Lego have string attached if
it really tangled up they literally have
they are completely independent they
have no dependencies in the outside
world and so they are completely musical
and we did the same thing with
functional program we were trying to
design our functions so they have no
dependencies on the outside world and
that means they're completely reusable
so the Lego philosophy makes you allows
you to make really big things by
building bigger things some smaller
things right and I call that the power
of composition have a whole talk about
that so how do we apply these ideas to
programming
well let's the plot let's transfer these
ideas to programming now I'm talking
about in this talk I'm talking about a
statically typed functional programming
but in fact you can you know a lot of
these ideas also work for non statically
type - so you design functions that do
one thing well and these functions can
be reused in different contexts and you
design the functions to work together
they all have bumps on them and that
means basically when you're coding you
always think that somebody could be
using this function in a way that I
didn't think about so you try and design
the output of the function in such a way
that people can't mess it up and then
you use the types in order to make sure
the bits fit together like with the Lego
you can't push them into the wrong slots
so doing the things that do one thing
well designing those little functions
that's the toolkit those those eleven
functions in the toolkit are very you
know they're tools that they do one
thing really well you don't use a hammer
for hitting nails
you know they do one thing well and you
can reuse them for that one thing so
composition this is how you compose two
functions here we have two functions one
is an apple - banana function and
another is a banana - cherry function
how do we connect them well this is why
I like the railway analogy because it's
really obvious how you connect let me
just like stick them together so that's
before and that's after
now what's interesting is we now have a
new function and you cannot contact you
cannot tell it's built from smaller
pieces the fact that it's made from
smaller parts we can't tell all you can
see is the insight unit input the output
at for example where - the banana
co-write the smaller functions cared
about bananas this function doesn't care
about an honest and so if I'm using this
function I don't need to know about
bananas so this kind of composition
thing you might think well yeah but can
you you know how far can you go with
this so you can start with low-level
functions like upper case in a string
that's a really simple function why you
give it a string and you get a string
back but you can take these low-level
operations and build them into the like
a service that does something like that
dress validation so obviously you feed
in some sort of dress that spits out
results and our service is a bit of a
strange word so anyone under 30 service
is just like a micro service yeah you
have to be over 32 no way so we take
these services and we combine them into
a use case or a scenario or a story or
work whatever I want to call it you know
they do various things they could work
together to make something happen and
then finally you take all these
scenarios the use cases whatever and you
build a web application now a web
application is actually a function it
takes in an HTTP request as input and it
spits out an HTTP responses output so
you can actually think of entire web
application as a function and in some
way there you have a controller or a
dispatcher or router whatever you want
to call it the decides based on the
input which one of these things to call
so that's a complete application built
for functions and so you can say that
composition is sort of fractal it works
you use the same techniques of there's
low level as you do the high level there
you don't have to switch between
different endings just like with Lego
use
same techniques in Lego when you're
putting two pieces together as smoothly
bring big things together so if you look
inside a web application this is what it
looks like there's these functions all
chained together but notice the arrows
go in one direction so unlike our way
even have kind of dependencies and all
sort of things the in front of the
project we didn't have this linear
pipeline thing where things tend to go
in one direction so that's the power
composition for functions as I said I've
got a whole talk of this if you go to my
website or just Google power composition
you'll find it right so let's look at
how this works in F sharp so I'm going
to show you some F sharp code now here
is this a simple function f sharp adding
one here's another simple function which
doubles it and in F sharp we use the let
keyword to define things in C sharp use
var or you know in other languages it's
def in dog language is whatever so that
defines a function and you can also
define functions using lambdas using the
fun keyword because fun is a keyword in
a shop that's why if shock is so great
so you know this is how you do a lambda
in a shop right so you can switch
between defining functions both ways all
right so let's compose some functions
now you say well let's say I want to add
one and then I want to double it and
then I want to square it now in a
traditional program if you do this by
using lots and lots of parentheses and
this kind of nested thing can get kind
of ugly sometimes I don't need so we
have to kind of work from the inside out
now a model I think is much nicer is
this pipeline model where you start with
a number and you feed it into add one
and you take the output of that and you
feed it into double then you take the
output of that and you've read it into
square and so on so forth now anyone
who's done any kind of UNIX come online
you know program programming this is you
know you have the pipe on the car -
exactly the same technique and I think
this is actually a much easier model to
understand and a functional programmers
tend to use this a lot more so an F
sharp is the way you do this is you have
a special pipe symbol which is the
vertical bar an angle bracket and I take
you know I take five and I feed it into
add one I take the output a bad one I
feed it a double they take the output a
double and I feed it into square and you
just you just pipe this little
so that's how when you look at F sharp
code you'll see a lot of code that looks
just like this all right so that's
composition of course that's it makes it
sound too easy right in real world it's
never that easy there's always
complications so let's look at the some
of the complications what happens if the
inputs and the outputs don't match up
properly so if the output is a banana
and the input or the next one Isabella
everything's good we're very happy but
if the input of the next one is a cherry
the banana and the cherry don't match
and you can't composer to hear
so one fix for that that doesn't work
one fix is to insert some sort of
conversion function into the pipeline so
we have a little ethyl to cherry
converter and we just stick it into
pipeline and then everything works let
me show you some real code here because
this is a contrived example but let's
say that we take output it add one and
we want to feed it into string length
now string length doesn't take in sit
take strings so you're going to get an
error when you try to do that so the
solution is to stick a new function into
this pipeline that turns into into
strings and that fixes that book so
that's pretty easy but that's tends to
be really not the most important problem
that you wanted to so you can fix things
that way more likely is you have a
situation where the types are sort of
the right type but they're they're
wrapped in something and they don't
match so you might return an optional
value an optional banana and you need to
feed it into something that has a banana
and the optional bananas and resins
don't match up or you have something a
banana and you need to have a list of
bananas and you can't turn a banana into
a list of bananas so they kind of match
up sort of but they still don't really
connect together properly and this is
really what we're going to solve with
the functional toolkit right the spoiler
tidiest by the way is Monas right right
so part two let's talk about function
transformers so we've got the basic
problem of composition how do we compose
things that don't fit properly and
really this is what we spend the rest of
the talk talking about
so we're gonna use a railway analogy
again we're always what do we always
have to do programming I keep talking
about it so here's a real-world scenario
let's say that I have a Web API web
service and I want to update my name and
email address so I'm gonna receive a
request and the request contains a name
and an email say and I'm gonna validate
the quest you know is the named not
blank is the email of our D mail and so
on maybe I want a lowercase the email
maybe trim stuff from the string and
then want to update the database okay
pretty simple straightforward kind of
thing to do now let's look at some code
so this is some C shop code and you know
we do the thing we take the request and
then we validate it and then we
lowercase the email and then we update
the data piece and then we return okay
whatever whatever it is that's great
it's really nice it's just a few lines
of code everything works great the only
problem is we don't have any error
handling so this is actually not
production quality code let's add the
error handling okay now since we and
error handling we have to say well what
happens if the validation doesn't work
what happens if you can't find the
customer record in the database what
happens if the database throws an
exception you know all sorts of things
that go well and your nice clean code
you're a couple of lines of code ends up
being really ugly and really complicated
and that's a shame because it was you
know if you wouldn't have to do error
handling it would be wonderful now let's
look at the functional equivalent so
what we're going to try and do is
preserve the simplicity the original
version that really nice is very simple
but it didn't have any are handling now
the the production quality version is
much more ready for production but it
looks horrible so can we have the get
the best of both worlds can it still
look simple but still do the error
handle so we're going to use this type
that functional programmers use a lot
which is result type and the result type
is basically a choice when you do
something like this you validate
something you can either either success
or failure it's like it is valid or it's
not valid and we represent this with a
choice type and this is how you write it
in their shop it's basically a choice
between two things you can think of this
as an enum you can think of this as a
class with two subclasses it doesn't
really matter how you think of it but
it's basically you've got a choice
between
two things and we in functional
programmers call these some types now
let's actually see how this is work so
we're gonna validate an input if the
name is blank that's bad so we're going
to say that's an error type we're gonna
use the ever choice if the email is
blank that's also bad I'm gonna return
an error but if everything is if those
are both fine then the whole thing is
good so we're going to see it okay we're
very unhappy path right now what's
interesting from the railway point of
view this looks awfully like a switch
function or a points function you have
one input and you have two outputs so
this is the metaphor I'm going to use
and you often run into the situation
where you have like a variation function
and it does something else and then
there's another function and there's
like one input but every possible thing
could have an error everything could
possibly fail and now the question is
how do you connect these kinds of
functions together now if you are well
way expert you'll know how to do this
right because you just do that so that's
before they're connected and that's
after they're connected so it's actually
really obvious how to connect them and
if you think about it but now the
question how do you actually implement
this part so I call this the two-track
model of error handling otherwise known
as a railway oriented programming and
again I have a talk about this if you're
interested know if we go back to the
original code and we update the customer
we know this is the functional version
now we've got the F sharp code with the
point being everything we take the
requests we pipe it into validate we
pipe it into the lower case we pipe it
into update and so on and so forth so
that's the the one track version without
any error handling just like the C shell
code now let's look at the same version
with the error handling okay so that's
before now with the error handling what
does it look like it looks like this you
take the requests you validate it feed
it into lower case the email you update
the database and so on and you're
thinking well that looks just the same
how can it be any different where's the
error handling and the answer is because
this is actually a two-track model so
the error handling is built into the way
the two-track system works so you get to
preserve the elegance of the original
that you still get all the benefits of
the nice area right so let's actually
look at the real code for implementing
this stuff so this is the function we
have we've got input we've got success
and failure we want to connect these
functions together and we want to say
worth it succeeds we want to do the next
thing if it fails we want to bypass we
want to get on to the error track and we
wanted to stay on the air track and says
listen if we can't validate the input
we're never gonna update the database so
we want to get to this point we want to
connect them together so how do we
compose these things well if we had one
track functions we could compose them
because they have we just connect the
input at the output and if we had to
track functions we could also compose
them because we connect the success
track to the other success track and the
failure track to the failure track that
would work fine too but that's we don't
have that we have this we have a one
input and two outputs and this doesn't
work so this is awful how do we combine
these mismatched functions and the
answer is bind this is a word you're
gonna hear a lot functional programmers
love the word bind they get very excited
by the word bind we're going to bind all
the things so here is our function and
as we said it's not suitable for
composition however if we had a
two-track version of that function with
two inputs that would be perfect that
would be just what we need now here's
the problem how do we go from the top
one which doesn't work at the bottom one
that doesn't work okay so what we're
going to do is create a it'll adapt a
block and if you think even though
wooden will waves have something like
this way you have a little square thing
and you slot your thing into it so
there's a two-track thing and it's got a
slot for the for the points or the
switch and we put this in the slot and
what comes out is one of those so this
is an adapter block that turns these
switcher points functions into these to
track functions this is exactly what we
want to solve our problem this is a
function transformer it takes a function
as input and spits out another function
as output
so the implementation is actually really
easy it's I'm going to say buying it's
got two parameters we parse in the to
track a input we're going to compare is
it the okay case or the error case if
it's the okay case then we're going to
call the next function if it's the error
case we're going to skip we're not going
we're just going to stay on the red
track and not do anything so that's the
complete implementation so the
implementation is literally three lines
of code it's one it we're gonna find all
today that I spend more time explaining
something than writing it once you
understand how these things literally
the implementations it's trivial but the
understanding is it's harder so once we
have this behind function we can take
our points functions like this and we
can turn them into bind and we can
connect them together so this thing of
using function transformer to convert
things from one thing is this like the
most important concept understand and
let's look at another some of this look
at how you do validation so let's say
that we want to validate the infant
again and how do we do that now before I
put it in one giant function but
probably you want to break it up into
pieces so I might want to violate the
name is not blank and maybe I want to
make sure the name is less than 50
characters because I'm putting in a
database then maybe I need to check the
emails not blank so writing smaller
functions is nicer because each each
little tiny function does one little
thing and then we use a boy I could
reuse the email one in another context
result so we have all these each of
these little functions is one of these
you know to track output functions and
again how do we combine them well the
first function we're going to leave
alone the second function we want to
compose with and the Third Point
remembers now that in order to actually
compose them well have to convert the
other two into these to track things so
we used bind so the first time we leave
alone we do bind on the second or we do
bind on the third one and once you've
done that we can connect them together
so let's actually look at the code we
take the first one and we pipe the
output into the second one we pipe the
output into the third one assuming
they've used bind on them so now that
solved our fact we've lived these
individual pieces and we've composed
them into a chain and what we can do is
we can give that whole thing a name
we can say to validate input here's the
three little functions we're going to
use we're going to chain them together
like that and we're going to give it a
name we call it validate the input just
like we did before and what's cool about
this is if we see it's a black box we
now have another function with one input
and two outputs
so this bigger function looks just like
smaller functions just like the Lego we
can keep going and going we can build a
bigger that we can actually connect this
to the other things and build a bigger
function out of it so this is how you
can build you can see how it will feel
bigger than some small things nicely so
we just keep going and going and we're
done now one thing to point out is that
the shapes and the types are kind of
different concepts when we're talking
about composing they're two tracks we're
talking about the shape of the track
right now the type of the data that goes
through can change as it goes through so
we could start off with an apple and it
can turn into banana and it can turn
into a cherry or whatever so the type
cans the type can changes as long as the
shapes match up so transforming the data
is fine it doesn't even have to be so
here's an example where the types match
up the bananas are the same and the
cherries are the same and the shapes are
the same so that's good now sometimes
the shapes do match up you put they're
both to track but the types don't match
up so you have a banana here and a
cherry here they don't match up so
you're gonna have to use this converter
thing like I said you have to turn
Bernards it's a cherry eseni not to make
it go right so that's that now one thing
we've talked about is these one input
and two outputs but sometimes you have
functions with one input and one output
so for example if we're going to
lowercase an email it can't go wrong
there's no error it's never going to
break so really it's just a one track
function one input one output so how
does that fit into the model the way
we're doing it right now is it doesn't
you know so what we did need to do same
thing we do before it's just use a
function transformer to convert that
into a two-track thing and we call this
map
and Matt works very much like mine
there's a slot you feed in this one
track function and it spits out a to TRO
function and the information from app is
really really easy to we just say you
know is the input good or bad if it's
good input we call that single track
function and we take the output of that
we turn it back into a success case and
if the infant is bad we just skip the
whole thing so again it's like a three
line implementation so now once we've
got this map function we can can turn
the we can fit that lowercase email into
our pipeline just by using math on it so
this is the principle we're doing here
we're converting everything into a
standard to track everything is
converted into the same shape as it were
so we had a single track function that
we convert it into to tow function we
have one of these points or switch
functions and we turned it into a two
track function and we'll find if we have
any other kind of weird functions we'll
turn them into two trig functions and we
just make them all into the same kind of
thing once they're all the same kind of
thing we can connect them together so
this is these map and bind our to
function transformers these are the
first two and actually poly the most
important function transformers the user
program so here's what we had before and
these things were not composable they
weren't able to be connected but after
we use these function transformers they
are able to be protected we've turned
everything into two tracks and we've
solved that problem so there we go
that's so that's what function
transformers are for so turning the
different shape functions into the same
shape function and this is really a set
up for the whole functional toolkit so
before I go into the functional toolkit
I need to talk about what I mean by
effects so what is an effect so an
effect is really just a kind of generic
type like for example lists is it in a
generic list is a kind of effect it
could be a type with extra data like
option or results it can be a type that
interacts to the outside will because
functional programmers hate to have
random stuff going on it's like you want
to make sure you really control how
interact outside well so in a
synchronous stuff with tasks or dealing
with random numbers or whatever you want
to make sure that's a special type
function programmers also use things
like States and parses special types to
represent things going on there it
doesn't really matter what it is it
could be all sorts of stuff and it
really doesn't matter what's what we're
really going to focus on in what is
common what are the patterns which are
calling behind all of these things so
the implementation might be slightly
different but there's a commonality
there's certain patterns which work for
them so I'm going to focus on three
types of this talk which is list option
and a sync and async is the F sharp
version of task or promise or future
we're gonna commit right so normal world
and effects world what do I mean by that
so in normal worlds you have things like
strings and integers and your boolean
and you also have functions you have a
function that turns an enter into string
and you have a function that turns into
a boolean and so on so you have this
kind of world or all these things these
are things you are used to now in option
world it's like a parallel universe
so everything in the normal world has a
kind of mirror image in option worlds so
every time there's a string in normal
well there's an option of string every
time there's an in in normal world
there's an option of it and there's an
option of Bourgh and just like the
functions in the normal world there are
functions in option world except the
functions always working options so you
know it's they're going into string
function you have a something attention
optional in international spring or an
optional inter optional bull so this
kind of if option word world is
something we're going to be coming back
to the same way there's a list world and
in list world everything is a list so
you have a list of strings and you have
a list of hints and you have a list of
balls and all the functions are list
functions they turn lists event into
lists of strings and lists of intint
listicles all right you can see where
I'm going with us you do the same thing
with async will async of spring async
event async of or more task of string or
tasks or whatever you wanna call it
again all the functions live in async
walls so think about these worlds is
going to be quite useful technique in
terms of understanding how to compose
things and you can see there's just a
generic pattern here it's like a generic
effect
whatever the effect is there's a flex
world where there's the effect of the
string and the effect of the int and the
effect of the ball and all the functions
of respective functions alright so if
you can understand that then you can
understand what I'm gonna be talking
about next now these these effects is a
it's like a functional programming
jargon
people call the effects some people call
them enhanced because it's like enhanced
values data it's like a value with extra
data like a result of an option
sometimes I call them elevated worlds
because we often talk about lifting
things from the normal world into this
other world so it's like lifting things
up into the higher world or an elevated
world so I'm gonna use e everything's in
EE worlds right so here's the challenge
how do we actually work with these
things I'll give you a real world
example so let's say I need to download
Yoel and I'm gonna it's gonna be some
Jason that comes out okay so I got Jason
and now I need to convert that Jason
into for example a customer DTO so cuz
in my domain and then that dto needs to
be converted into a valid customer so
I'm gonna do some validation on it make
sure it's good and then I'm going to
store that customer in a database okay
so this is a kind of example tsunami ax
if we look at the things of how it works
you know we download the JSON file we
start off in the normal world but the
Downloads it might be asynchronous and
it might only not work so it's an async
containing a result so it we're trans
were traveling between another world if
I'm trying to decode the Chasen into
into one of my objects that might or
might not work because that might but my
got the time small so the Jason is in
the normal thing it's like a string but
when I decode it I'm like a result they
might not work so I'm now moving into
another world when I do some validation
you know I start with a normal DC oh and
I validate each field that the
validation may be errored right there
each each piece of validation be an
error so I have a result for that to
construct a valid customer from either
the name and the email is valid and I
want to construct a customer from that
that's fine that's all normal world
stuff so there's nothing special there
and then finally when I want to store
the customer in the database I start
with a customer and again it may be
asynchronous and it may not work so it's
a async that's continuing the result so
here's the problem how do we compose
these things together that's the problem
they're all all kind of going in
different directions and stuff so there
none of the worlds matchup this is where
the functional tool kit comes in so
let's start with options here's our
novel world and here's the world of
options now when you're working with
options you often do this thing where
you have some sort of function that
returns an optional value or nullable
value if you replace option with
nullable if your language doesn't have
options just replace everything I say
with no level so you go to this world
and then you need to do something with
this you kind of come back down to the
normal world to do something go back up
to the option will you go down and go
back up you go down this is a really bad
way of doing things
so in front of the phone list is like so
on anti pan what you really want to do
is when you go to the option world you
want to go up there and you want to stay
up there there's long as possible now
you might have to come down at the very
end you know just to return a string in
your HTTP whatever but you try and stay
up in this world as long as possible
that's the right doing it so here's my
add one function this is a normal world
function now if I try and use it on an
optional value I get an error because
add one doesn't work with options it
only works with normal things right so
let's say well I'm gonna watch special
function called add one to an option and
if the option is valid if it's something
I'm gonna call add one on it and then
I'm going to take that value and wrap it
back up in an option and if it's not
valid I'm gonna turn nothing right now
this is the same thing I'm talking about
you're unwrapping it you're doing the
thing and you're wrapping it back up
again
this is like not how to do it don't come
down and do something and go back up
again right so if you if you catch
yourself doing this try and think about
doing another way so what is the other
way how do you how do you add one
function and stay up in option Wells the
add one isn't an option function so what
we want to do is the this is our first
tool which is the map function
moves things between worlds here's our
option our add one to options is the
really explicit function that only works
in one particular case let's make it
generic alright let's make it a generic
function so I'm gonna do is part in a
parameter like what is the thing that I
want to do well I don't care it could be
anything so I'm going to pass that thing
in as a function then I'm gonna call it
f because I have no idea what the
function is it could be anything
the program has functional programs to
use these very short letters sometimes
because what can you out what else can
you call it you know so I'm gonna run
that function on whatever the value is
and make something otherwise it's
nothing so that's my prioritized version
of this functional that's good that's
better but I can go further what I can
do is have a lambda version so I'm
actually going to rewrite this so it
returns the whole thing returns the
lando returns a function and the input
to this lambda is an option and the
output of this lambda is another option
so this whole thing this lambda is an
option two option function and the input
the prior I've given it which is in
normal world is a normal world function
so what we've got here is a function
that turns normal world functions into
option world functions and if you look
at it on the picture like this it's like
here's my op here's my normal function
and I use this this option map turns it
into an optional world function so
that's what map is that is a function
transformer that turns normal world
functions into optional world functions
so when I have this map function I can
then work on anything so one having away
a special thing of add one I can say
option map of add one and now the add
one has been moved into optional worlds
and I can use it with options without
any problem let's do the same thing for
lists
here's adding one to each item in a list
okay
so for each item in the lists I add one
to it and I put it back in a new list
and I return the new list again this is
super super specific for add one it's
like I would never buy a function like
this because I'm unwrapping it and
wrapping it you know applying and
wrapping up
doing exactly what I said you shouldn't
do you don't want to come down do the
thing go back so this is the same pan so
even we're talking about lists and sort
of options it's the same kind of pattern
so even though working with lists it's
different from working with options
we're making the same kind of mistake so
again let's make a generic we're gonna
pass in a parameter what do we want to
do with each item in the list we'll pass
in a function f and for each item the
lists will call that function f to get a
new item so now we've parameterised it
and then what we'll do is we'll lambda
rise it as well so we've now got a
lambda which takes a list as input and
it spits a list as output and again our
little parameter is a normal function so
what I've done again is we've taken
we've created a function that takes
normal world functions and puts them
into your list of other functions so
that's great and now we can use it just
like we did before we can say add one we
turn into list and use it for that and
people say why is this any better than
writing run loops it's because it's a
pattern once you recognize this pattern
you know a bunch of stuff about it I
know for example I know that Matt can
never change the length of a list it's
always gonna be seen under item so I can
just tell straight away if I've seen at
full there was something I would never
really be 100% sure all right and you
can do the same thing for async you can
have a sink map that turns normal
functions into a sink world so most
generic functions most generic types
that list and may have an option that
they have a map function use it and if
you write your own generic type write a
map function for good use now in FP
terminology this is called a functor so
a functor is some sort of effect type
like optional list or async plus a map
function which is called map or it can
be called select or it can be called
lift there's lots of different names of
this thing and it has to have a sensible
implementation known as the functor
clause it's basically it's just to make
sure you have a sensible implementation
right what about tool number two which
is moving values between worlds this is
really easy we have a value in normal
world and we want to move it up to the
world option
and that's normally called return like
here's the example you know it's
different for each type of thing so to
make an option you say it's something
that's really easy so normal world value
and an optional world value and for
making a list you can take a single item
and make it into a lists and list return
or list singleton whatever you want to
call it again to make a single item list
is really easy so there's nothing
special about this type of function list
is useful in combination with other
functions right what about bind that's a
familiar word so what's a world's
crossing function I'm going to be
talking about world crossing functions
so here it is a function you give me a
maximum integer and I give you a list of
integers up to that maximum value so
this is a function that takes the
integer and returns a list of integers
so we start the input is the list that
is a normal value and the output is in
list world okay so this is a world
crossing function you start down at the
bottom and you end up higher up what
about getting a customer from a database
you give me a customer ID and I'm going
to try and get the customer from a
database so if the customers found I'm
not actually going to show the database
code obviously somehow you do the
database query if the customers found
you're gonna say yeah here's some custom
later I'm gonna give it to you if the
customer isn't found I've got nothing to
give you so we're gonna return nothing
so again this is a function that crosses
worlds you give me a customer ID and I
might or might not we'll give you a bad
customer data is an optional I give you
back an optional customer so we start
off with the value in normal world and
we end up with a value in functional
world so here we are customer ID down
here option customer data up here these
world costing functions are really
common so how do you cheney's things
together so let's say we have options we
have an option world we do something and
it returns an option and we want to do
something else well if the option is
something then we can do the next thing
and if that is something we can do the
next thing and if that is something we
can do the next thing and so on and if
any of them are nothing then we have
this kind of skip right so this pattern
is very common when you have these world
crossing functions
you have these nested checks you keep
nesting and nesting and nesting nesting
and people call this the pyramid of do
because it looks with you although now
you see this all over world I mean you
see this with tasks so that it's not
just options tasks are the same thing
you run a task and when the task is
finished you do the next task and when
the task is finished you do the next
task when the tarsals finishing the next
tiles and so on exactly the same kind of
thing you get this nested pyramid this
nested indent and nested callbacks and
this pyramid so anytime you have these
world crossing functions you're going to
run into this pattern okay so how do we
solve this pattern how do we fix this
problem let's look at the option one and
notice there's a pattern that we can
exploit if it's something do something
otherwise do nothing if it's something
do something otherwise do nothing if
it's something do something otherwise do
nothing that's the pattern we can
exploit so let's take it let's make a
little helper function to that we're
going to call it you know if it's
something then do something otherwise do
nothing all right that's the pattern how
do we make a helper function well we
have a little we don't exactly know what
you want to do with it so we're going to
parameterize it with a pair thought with
a function parameter so here's the
actual helper function if something dude
I'm going to call it if the option is
something do it what is it we're going
to do we don't know otherwise return
nothing so whatever it is we're going to
do we don't know what it is so we're
going to pass it in as a function
priority so this if some do is that it
really useful it will help a function
and you know go back to our original
example we can say well do something if
it's something do the next thing if it's
something do the next thing if it's
something do the next thing
so we've taken our kind of pyramid shape
and turned it in a nice linear
up-and-down shape much easier to read
and let's revisit that well way analogy
because it's very similar
instead of having success and failure we
have something or nothing for options
and we've already seen this if it's
something to the next thing if it's
nothing to do that I pass it so we're
going to follow exactly the same thing
we did before we want to cheney's
together and we're going to use bind
again and we're going to do this thing
where we have these functions that don't
fit
and we want to turn them into the
functions that do fit and we're going to
write a bind function which is a
transformer function and this time the
code is slightly different because we're
talking about options rather than
results but the idea is exactly the same
so it's another function transformer so
in this case defined for options we say
if the option is something do the next
thing and if the option is nothing keep
going on the error path now it turns out
that's exactly the function we just
wrote that if something do function is
exactly the same limitation so this you
know option example that we wrote with
the nested thing which is ugly and
horrible we use this option buying
function like I say it's exactly the
same as that if something do function
exactly same implementation right and
it's parameter is exactly the same way
and we can then turn our original ugly
code into something nice and clean no
pyramid anywhere and let's do the same
thing for tasks let's get rid of the
task pyramid here's how you change you
task together if the task completes or
when the task completes you do the next
thing otherwise if the task doesn't
complete you bypass it right so that's
the when finish to do so let's do the
same thing here's the uh none untidy
version with a nesting and there so on
which is really ugly so we're going to
write a helper function called when
finished do otherwise known as bind
alright so when the thing is finished we
can do something whatever the next thing
is but we don't know what it is so we'll
just pass in a function parameter for
that there's the function parameter
we're passing in and once we have this
task finished do or task bind we can
make our pyramid logic much more simple
with a straight linear line so there you
go so bind is like one of the most
important functions in important
concepts in functional programming
because it makes world crossing
functions composable you know this is
the original version of our functional
it's a world crossing function it starts
in normal world ends up in an effects
world whether it's an option or a list
or results or an async what it was after
we do binds we have a
horizontal function so it's the whole
function lives in the effects world so
after we did bind we had the option
input option output or we had to list in
put this down what are they thinking
but task input task out from whatever
and if you go back to the railway model
it's like this is what this is the world
crossing function we said and after we
did bind we have this nice to track
model so you can see this is really
really powerful and you often have this
situation where you have a bunch of
world crossing functions or diagonal
functions and you need to chain them
together and so what bind does is it
allows them to be composed because the
diagonal functions as they stand cannot
be composed but if you do bind and you
make it into a horizontal function and
you bind the next one and you make it
into horizontal function you buy the
next one you make it horizontal I'm sure
you now have a bunch of holes on the
functions and you can glue them all
together all right so the whole point is
trying how can we make our functions
composable that's what mine's all about
so an FP terminology that's what a monad
is so we've been talking about mode as
its whole time monad is an effect type
plus something return plus a bind
function basically it's a type plus a
bind function plus some rules about how
to implement now the buying function is
all sorts of different names in other
languages it's called flat map it's
sometimes called when then do or when do
in c-sharp is called select many you
know link and it has to have a sensible
implementation but that's all a monad is
is really just a tight manner and an
Associated bind operation so use a monad
if you want to chain effects generating
functions in series right I'll quickly
talk about applicatives for doing
parallel stuff if you want to combine
effects in parallel
sometimes you want to have both things
like if you were combine two options you
want to get an option that contains the
pair like if you have some 42 and some
hello you want to have 42 and lower but
you know if one of them is missing the
overall thing is missing similarly if
you have two lists and you want to
combine them we want to get a list of
pairs or something here's a list of all
pairs or you might want to have the list
of pairs that way either across products
or as oppressed so this is a general
concept inflation ponycorn on your
ticket of funk sure it's the same kind
of thing it's like a monad like a
functor it's a way of combining things
in the effects world and you preserve
them you know you can bind them together
in parallel so let's look an example
yeah there's the picot
all this stuff you don't really have to
worry about the jargon really the jargon
I'm gonna throw this out here but don't
worry about the job sometimes you see
the word lift and we're actually going
to use the word lift sometimes you see
the word apply these are all different
variants of this kind of concept
sometimes you see angle brackets with a
star in the middle that's the high
school version of this right so why is
this useful because you're going to do
things in parallel here's our customer
and we've got our validation logic right
the problem with chaining them in series
is that as soon as the first one fails
the rest of them fail and we never get a
list of errors we just get the first
error so it'd be quite nice rather than
change them in series we'll only get one
hour at a time is to get all the errors
at once all the validation errors at
once and in order to do that we have to
run them in parallel like this so we one
each feel gets validated separately and
then we combine them in parallel and
that's exactly what the applicative team
does we get all the errors at once so
you know just like we had before we've
got all these in independent results
from the validation that we want to
combine them now we have a we have a in
normal world we have a way of combining
them we just call a constructor or you
know a function that makes these things
so that's not a problem we know how to
combine them in normal world but we
don't know how to combine them in result
worlds and what we want to do is combine
them in the result world and have the
output also being result world so we
have all these errors and we combine
them to make a customer and if any of
them are not valid we get an error on
that side too so that's what I flick it
is for you're combining things in result
world to make a new result or
complaining things in this world we can
you list or combining things in a sink
or two we can use a sink or whatever and
these functions are normally called
lifts like a for applicative lifts a 2
is a 2 parameter lift
lift a3 a3 frowns and lifts so if I just
like we had a list map which would have
a one-parameter function lift it up lift
to will lift up a two parameter function
so this one has the two parameters lift
three will lift up a three parameter
function and so on
so if you see lifts is doing the same
thing as markets moving it from one
world to another world so if you look at
the code to convert our detail into a
customer we validate the name it could
be valid me or it could be an error we
valid an email it could be a valid name
or an error and found that in one area
we validate the birthday could be father
of an error and now we want to try and
make a customer out of these things and
so we use they'll make customer function
and we lift it into result wells and
once we lift it into result worlds we
can pass in those three parameters and
we get back a results containing a
customer so that's the magic I'm not
gonna explain how it works but it's kind
of magic and we get a nice list of
errors rather than a single error back
so again don't worry about I picked it's
working too much just be aware that if
you want to do if you want to chain
things in parallel using applicative if
you want to change things in series use
them own app all right so let's look at
the tools so we've been talking about
we've talked about a map which lifts
things into a fix world return this
individual items individual values like
Springs and int into FX world bind the
four diagonal functions well forcing
functions apply or lift for combining
things in parallel right so let's use
all the tools together let's actually
solve that real world problem that I
talked about so we had downloading a URL
downloading the Jason converting VTO etc
so downloading the JSON file we started
the URL and we end up up here
decoding the jason we started in the
normal world and we ended it in results
the validation feels we end up in
results constructing the customer was
all normal stuff and then storing the
customer in the database was normal
world to async result world alright so
let's look at we can use the tools to
compose though before we didn't know how
that we didn't know how to do it now we
do know how to do it so let's start with
the validation
we've got these three results and we
want to make a customer ask them and we
saw how to do that using the applicator
using this three so that's good that's
one thing so now what we do is we now
have a normal DTO in normal world and we
have a customer in results world so
that's that particular problem solved so
there's our DTO to customer that's a
diagonal world busing function we also
have the jason to the DTO
that's also a diagonal function because
the DTO you might the jason might not
work it might be invalid so we have
these two diagonal functions and we want
to connect them together we want to take
the output of the the jason which is the
DTO and we want to feed that into the
next one right and as they as they stand
they can't be connected but if we use
bind that will solve a problem we're
going to use bind and make them both
horizontal like that
now they're both horizontal we can
connect them all together to make a big
function so now we have a big function
that starts off with jason and ends up
with a customer so the DTO is now
hitting the banana has now gone away all
right so there's our new function so
we're building bigger functions and
smaller functions now we're going to
reuse this function in in the in the
overall bigger picture right so this is
what the code looks like again the code
is really simple we do a bind and
another bind literally three lines of
code and again takes much more time to
explain it than to actually write it
alright so now we have this now our
final thing is living up in in in async
result world and this is not there this
is in result world but it's not in async
result world so we need to move it up
another level need to move it one stage
higher how do we do that how do we move
a function from one world to another
world we use map so we're going to use
map to lift it up to the async wall now
so our original function which is kind
of all these diagonal functions that
didn't fit together we've flattened them
out horizontally and we've lifted them
up so now we have a final function which
works up in the async world and it's
horizontal it's gonna be easy to compose
right now what about storing the
customer in the database that was also
another diagonal function and again it's
not composable as it stands but again we
can
use bind we're gonna take this thing
we're going to turn it horizontal like
that and now we have a horizontal
function that lives entirely in async
will so now if you look at all the
different steps we have with the
original step was downloading URL and
that made an async results which
contains and jason and now we have the
jason - customer function which we built
from the various pieces and that now
lives in a single result world because
we started off down and results we did
the map to lift it up and the other
function which was storing a customer
into a database again that was
originally a diagonal function and we
made a horizontal so it's now a purely
async world function and these are all
async wall functions and they can all be
composed together really nicely now so
we start here we go up we compose and we
compose and we can connect these
together and make it into one giant
function so this is how you use the
tools to do real stuff and again it's
more complicated to explain if we
actually look at the code there's the
code we had before and this is the this
is the the actual main function that
downloads and stores a customer you
start with the URL you download it you
convert it adjacent you do the jason to
customer conversion then you have to do
it in the extinct wills and then finally
you store the customer in the databases
and that has to use buying you know so
it's six lines of code or eight lines of
code these patterns are very unfamiliar
initially but once you see these
patterns you'll be able to look at this
code and know exactly what it does right
so much more time to explain than to
write it but you can get once they're
common patterns once you know what they
are this mean it easy to use right so
final thing is all this buying stuff can
get really ugly and so a lot of
functional programming languages
actually have support from monads built
in so if you solve of F shelf has
something called computation expressions
Haskell has do notation Scala has for
conventions C sharp has select many so
you can actually overload select many to
do a lot of this stuff for you that's
kind of cool right so finally just want
to remember that functional programming
jargon is actually not that scary
hopefully the concepts makes sense even
if the words are a bit scary hopefully
you can see why monads are such a big
deal and everyone talks about motors all
the time if you think about buying
monads you can see why that's valuable
this is a very generic toolkit all the
spined and math and stuff you know this
is a concept the worse for any effects
will so not just for options not just
for results not just async anything and
so as a functional programmer you
basically use these kinds of functions
over and over for everything you do and
now when you see if you look at
functional coder you see map and left
and bind you'll know what people talking
about like I say don't expect to
understand everything straight away so
I'm gonna post the slides of videos on
my website at some point if you're
interested in some of the stuff I've
talked about I have over later talk
which is functional design patterns I
have another one called the pram
composition I have another one called
domain mod naming functional and I have
a whole book about domain modeling and
functional so if you're interested in
that let me know I think is actually for
sale at the bookstore here contact me on
Twitter and thanks very much
[Applause]